it's me I'm back I know you missed me
it's me it's me it's me yeah it's me
it's on it's on it's me hi it's Jake
what episode number is it I can't be
bothered to keep I never can remember
right at the beginning of the thing when
I talk to you at the beginning of the
thing but I do know that it's been a
while since I talked to you but not as
long as it was the last time that I
didn't talk to you because I'm feeling
better hey I had a great time in austin
texas if you came to any of those shows
I can now at this point express my
sincere gratitude to you thank you that
was such a fun time and I think we I
think we both had fun hbu and I so thank
you and if you didn't make it to that
come see another show so I'm to go to my
website check this com see the podcast
is called Jake this podcast I've got a
website Jake this calm and i'm at take
this on Twitter all that stuff so you go
to my website you can see i'm gonna be
coming up to seattle it to laughs in
kirkland it's not in kirkland anymore
though now it's back and see how i got
the wrong address on my website go to my
website but don't trust everything used
to you here so i'm coming up to seattle
to laughs I'm coming to Des Moines to
the funny bone I'm coming to Denver the
comedy works i'm coming to governors in
Levittown New York longisland I'm gonna
be at the hollywood improv i'm going to
Zanies in chicago and rosemont i'm going
up to san francisco and to be in irvine
i'm doing a lot of things so go to those
places and to click those links and do
that thing and this week on my podcast
this podcast the thing you listening to
what's about to happen to you I'd like
to answer that question thank you for
asking and I'm a quick update on the
yoga pants I ordered some of those yoga
pants I was talking about last time
not here yet but I've I can't wait I got
sucked down a rabbit hole of yoga pants
and this is how susceptible I am to
marketing I know what they're trying to
do I know when you go into the search
engine and they say check these yoga
pants out you start looking at them and
then the next thing you know you want
them then you look at the men's but
they're not real I don't know their yoga
pants it could be dress pants will see
what they're like when they show up
that's all I can say anyway I ordered
some of those and so check here for
further updates but this week on the
podcast my friend who greg behrendt
stops by and we had a conversation we
didn't talk as much about fashion and
pants as we usually do so that's why I
wanted to mention pants at the beginning
because I know he does like to talk
pants but he was over we took a walk
around the neighborhood looked at some
venues you know and we were plotting
were plotting a future together he and I
where we'll do some live shows and so
I've got the sound system which I showed
him and I said look my dream is to
figure out a place where we can do some
spontaneous shows either in the you know
we can kind of take this thing anywhere
that can hold a hundred people and so if
you have a place like that you know in
the back of a bar your foreign legion
Foreign Legion Hall I think American
Legion is what i meant to say but if you
are part of a american chapter the
French Foreign Legion and you've got a
space where we can go would be happy to
I'd be happy to entertain any
suggestions so we're looking right now
to do things that we can drive to from
here in Southern California but I'm also
looking to try and get out on the road
and do some more home 80 to my regular
comedy show is homemade I said I mean I
make it at home I cook it up right in my
brain and serve it up to you hot or
pretty warm some sometimes it's not you
know I'm not part of that comedy thing
where it's like I'm trying to ride a
cutting edge and teach you a lesson I'm
just trying for us to have a good time
and if I say any true things at the same
time while we're out that's bonus more
power to us more power to its more power
to you it's not just about me it's about
us that's how I like to think about it
we're all in this together don't forget
we're all in this together we
to help each other out and stuff instead
of cut each other off which seems like
that is the plan you driving around half
the time people act like it's a
competition I mean I'm an imam in
Southern California where I know there's
not that many people watching NASCAR but
people act like oh they gotta don't let
you in because they got to get where
they're going and if you know to take
the opposite attitude and really try and
help that other person out pretend it's
your mom pretend I'm your mom pretend i
am your mocha that's a whole kettle of
fish but pretend that you're trying to
help each other out every once a while
then before you know it you'll actually
will be helping each other out and then
the world is going to get to be nicer
but that is part of why i had my friend
greg behrendt come over today or
yesterday but could be today to you it's
today to you because you're listening to
this right now so this is today there is
no time but the present the past is
history and the futures of mystery the
president is a gift I that's the thing
that I knew that I didn't know that I
was going to say right now but I got
into it we're in the present so this is
happening to you today but it happened
to me yesterday but who knows what day
that'll be by the time you're actually
listening to this so or everything's
relative equals mc-squared don't forget
that and c is the speed of light that's
constant which is hard to believe
because everything's relative except for
the speed of light hmm Einstein too bad
he's dead we could ask I got questions I
have got questions they'd probably be so
boring me asking Einstein questions man
how bad what if you could wake him up
what you know this is there that I would
back to the go go have dinner with the
famous person and just what kind of a
social burden that would be for you to
have dinner with your dream person
because Einstein let's face it I'm
doubting I might be able to ask him a
couple of good quest he would probably
super excited that he was alive again
for a minute of like holy crap it was
dark I was alone for so long or that's
assuming that there that he's not in
some kind of paradise with Marilyn
Monroe which that's that's where I like
butts let's all picture Einstein and
Marilyn Monroe kind of getting into some
pre like looking across a nice table
with the remains of a delicious meal and
maybe
got a about a half a glass of wine to go
and they just they're into it they can't
wait to see what's going to happen next
that's how I like to Pat picture
Einstein right now and so he's
immediately winked out of that too here
in my little office patha torium we're
only yesterday I talked with greg
behrendt and now I'm asking Einstein
some questions about the relativity and
the speed of light I doubt I could
understand the answers that's the
problem that's the problem let's say
your dog could talk for just 30 seconds
and it ask you all these questions you
might be able to understand the
questions with the dogs I can be able to
understand the answers and that's poor
Einstein I feel sorry for him but no I
just made all that up undecided still
finishing that glass of wine with
Marilyn Monroe but right now it's time
for us to listen to me talk to greg
behrendt and I just let me just say
thank you for listening to so far I mean
you were seven minutes into this thing
and I'm the only one talking I well I
can only I'm assuming that you might be
talking the whole time you might be
having retorts and rejoinders to me and
I can't wait to download your podcast
shoot me an email let me know where I
can do it okay here we go this is I'm
going to play the theme music we're
gonna listen to Greg Barrett's I'm gonna
be back at the end that's how we used to
do it before it got to the point where I
was just sitting alone crying in my
underpants trying to get my head
together to do another episode but at
that time that's in the past I'm not
saying it's not coming back it comes
back before you know that's the thing
you feel like you're on a roll and
you're not going to be crying and your
underpants anymore and then you're back
at it if I could play the guitar this
would be a song and then we'd all be
happier but here's this this is it it's
me and greg behrendt here we go
I didn't have any breakfast I was this
thing about that I was like did I have a
breakfast this morning normally I get up
and get a breakfast by made 14 I made
one for true well yeah children Jordan
have to eat breakfast yeah yeah she had
a waffle and some bananas and you have a
waffle we have to have a waffle maker to
make waffles yeah I didn't make waffles
that's a bay i toasted a Belgian waffle
house oh it was a tough like yeah it's
like one of those fancy ones from you
know trader joes or its a good it's a
good waffle me I wasn't trying to take
away from no no but you know they don't
taste this kid a waffle really is a
waffle is age is a just off the griddle
thing yeah off the griddle it's like a
toasted donut or something you know I
mean like it's a pastry treat it's not
as good as it could be no not as good as
it could be yeah all right I don't think
the waffle gets enough play I think the
pancake gets a lot more play what man
cakes are easier because you just need a
pan but if you want to have waffles you
got to have a waffle iron or else you're
buying the ones that you're talking
about what you're not i mean it is a
waffle but it's yeah it's a it's jacked
with preservatives I mean that waffle
got made and then bagged and then
shipped yeah and then weeks weeks ago
with the waffle was waiting Hawk
becoming yeah yeah like a puppy unison
they got frozen four wives we weren't
going to eat it right away I mean I mean
that waffle was meant to be eaten seven
or eight months after it was born you
know well I hot and then it wasn't hot
for another seven or eight months I bet
that those waffles also though they are
not meant to be like if you ate it right
off it came right when it came out of
the waffle extruder whatever the thing
is it probably would taste weird because
an extruder I don't think so but I like
that word and I wanted to say that
waffle extruder yeah but if you ate it
right it when it came out of that thing
it would probably taste weird cuz it's
not meant to be it's meant to be frozen
like the things that make it so you can
freeze it do all the things you want to
do I mean there is a Belgian waffles
what you know
it claims to be and it's so it's
roundish and it's got a lot of cinnamon
on it and it's all right you know what I
mean but everything frozen cooked its
bread tastes like oh this is just frozen
it never feels like it wasn't frozen
yeah I guess I'm so used to bagels out
of the freezer now that I got there
there okay to me why would you totally
do that yeah once you toast them but
then now you've changed the whole bagel
experience too because of bagel really i
think is best just what they'll just
like warm right out of the just chewy
well you know whom you would like his
Murray ball Ariano because I like Murray
yeah he can't believe that when I went
over to his house he promised he said I
got bagels I was like great he doesn't
even have a toaster he has one now but
he is now attended really because
because he just like something he just
thought that you would like them he
thought everybody just likes him just
right out of the bagel bag you and you
and true true love's it lightly toasted
please if I could have everything
toasted I would almost i like it just a
little brown and crispy yeah yeah i mean
the true has that OCD thing or the
shower or the another sarahbooth that
cream cheese has to cover all of the
circle and then but not fall into the
middles and then she fingers that like
she so it's just exactly covered with a
certain amount of cream cheese like
Washington do it you know I just slather
and then I dropped the knife on the
table and not put in there yeah thinking
I got some ritual I've got some tidy
rituals I think I'm on the spectrum I
think we're all in the spectrum oh yeah
I have a little bit of that I have a
little bit of that i actually prefer it
I when I don't live in that if I don't
if I'm not allowed to live in that
comfort zone I go the opposite direction
but I like to have a handful of things I
like to be tidy and have less you know
I've been married to Belinda now for 14
gamos 14 years and I still cannot get
used to the way that she cuts up a piece
of fruit like an animal mm-hmm she will
just slice off the edge of an apple
random like she doesn't know like
there's a center cylinder core thing
you want to deal with that and get the
seeds out but maintain the minimum
amount of Apple meet loss and right but
she'll trim it down and they'll be this
weird shaped thing that's got some of
the core in it and it's very frustrating
to me but I can't she doesn't want to do
it the way that I do it and I've stopped
trying to get her to cut the Apple the
way I want to cut it but I haven't
stopped wanting to that's the real so
that's probably that's the but that's
the actual problem right there yeah I
really hadn't been able to say it you
were quiet for long enough that I
finally figured it out hi I'm not able
to have these kind of conversations when
it's just me but it takes another person
sitting here and then I can talk and now
I know you can get it out yeah the
problem is not that she won't cut the
Apple the way that I want her to cut it
the problem is I can't let go of wanting
her to cut it that way yeah yeah I'm not
allowed to use any of the knives in my
house so that's where that happens I've
stabbed myself on a number of occasions
and taking pieces of my finger often the
mare was like like when I start to cut a
bagel she just please god no just let me
just put all the sharp just leave
it alone just ask me ask minute cut it
for you you have to ask her to cut it I
I don't usually because I don't know
what was I'm not a child but I but she
would just prefer to do it and so there
are certain things I won't cut like an
apple she peels him for the kids and
does that thing I I can't do that i mean
that's that's the end of me if i wanted
to commit suicide i'd do it by peeling
an apple that's how i do it I'd slip I'd
slice my wrists and you wouldn't be
killing yourself just trying to kill
yourself you would just know that look
at my trying example I know I tried a
scale like that if I want to kill myself
I would be trying to kill myself but
rather than just stabbed myself I would
do it doing the Apple cousin I didn't
wouldn't know when it was coming I
wouldn't know which slice was gonna be
the one more fun ain't none of me is
over yeah yeah so it's like I've I know
it's gonna happen but not exactly when
and there's element of surprise and then
people would be like did he kill himself
or did he mess up with an apple I don't
know if anyone's ever died cutting an
apple mmm
I bet they I mean it's a big world and
there's a lot of people of but I don't
know yeah I don't think so probably yeah
probably yeah it's pretty probably not
well there's always you Lou you're using
the wrong tool for the job might be
somebody like that right right you know
right i just figured i could shoot the
skin off nope yeah it's not gonna work
why thought maybe samurai sword i was
still keeping it knife e yeah that you
went right for the gun yeah yeah guns
are dangerous if you're getting a gun
out to do any kind of food prep but that
seems it's not killing that's not murder
I mean there's you've got to murder
these animals to be able to eat them but
can you see that like in a movie where a
guy guy goes wanna see me peel this
Apple and they throws it up in the air
and just hits it three times with a
bullet and it spins it and takes them
just on the side that bap bap spins it
he drops into his hand it's
peeled that's a good scene doesn't
really good logic that doesn't seem like
it I think that's a comedy with that
that that that happens in I don't know
Quentin Tarantino might be able to pull
it off if you do that an independent
film to it like that was just the one
that's the money you spent the one trick
on you like he that's your one seat boy
when we went into that yeah cuz we were
if it was in an independent film I would
just do it here in your office and then
you'd be wondering why I shot holes in
the roof of your off yeah yeah well I
have I'm I gotta order those you know
you're not supposed to bring a handgun
in here California you can't just bring
a handgun anywhere matter but there are
you know like Missouri I think they've
got to put a sign up like you can take
your gun everywhere except for places
where they put up a sign that says hey
can't take your gun in here and then
that place you have to leave your gun in
the car which I don't understand why
everyone wouldn't say you got to leave
your gun in the car I mean I just feel
like if you're offering laser to if
laser tag or movies or a bar or
restaurant it's like no good guns aren't
going to make this better no ah no but
those are all I mean you know yeah no no
I so I always freaked out by that
because there's a couple cities where we
do stand-up where they have open carry
and you know I've I've seen a guy in
there with a gun
and you know that just is so I mean I
know they don't every place has its own
like when I was in Texas um the one
night there was a table of guys and I'll
a cowboy hats on they were look like
they were like rodeo people and they guy
had it literally had a seat for his hat
and I said as a seat for your hat he
said that it was right I said that is
dude I hope you paid because I know
that's that's a seat that could be your
has places yeah you know i mean i can't
i hope this are we pro rating this and
then I and then right next to him was
this table of I'm not kidding roster
lesbians like dreadlocked and braided
lesbian Wow yes I feel like that's in
the eye it's not wrong it's not heard
watching but it's whatever you're
calling it yeah you don't see that you
don't it was really it was very like um
it was very like oh my god you guys are
we look at this I don't I feel like you
don't see rasta ladies that often oh you
don't you don't and this was cornrows
and dreads and they were definitely gay
they you know like they were definitely
well that might otherworldly hands and
stuff so they but they were sometimes
ladies would do that you could tell
though they had a there was like a you
if you if I really broke it down there
was I got a butch tibia tune on butch
written a nervous what could be a
culture thing know that you don't
understand me like arab guy arab guys
will walk around holding hands with
another dude yeah they're not gay looks
like hey we're hanging this is how we do
it right well that's because they're not
allowed to be I don't think they're
supposed to get at all so this is
probably the best way to just sort of
when we just let them hold hands at
least that way just make it a closed no
I'm saying they're not gay I'm saying
you and I know I know they are all once
we're arab guys but I'm saying I think
the custom exists because it was agreed
upon thing where people said look we
can't have gay we don't have gays in our
world so everybody's got to do a little
bit of a gay so if we just let the
hand-holding make the handle anything
actually the thing that guys do
everybody does a couple guys and then
that way that way you straight guys are
kind of the cover for the gay guys who
are holding it there get my secret
thrill out of it like I can't believe
I'm holding this dude
yeah yes exactly it's totally okay
exactly so um um I'm still wanna I still
want to peel that apple with a gun I
don't know where you go to practice that
but no I never gonna have it but if you
find out I'll come and watch it's a good
I think I man it put it into a movie I'm
have written so many movies none and so
I don't know which movie I'm gonna put
it in but i'll put it in it's just
having ideas or conversations i think i
said this to the to the other day is
like my idea of heaven is you know we
just talk it would just sit in a room
and talk about things that we're going
to do when we leave the room and then we
never leave right now just sit around we
just drink coffee yeah we'll bring us
food yeah we take a nap and we just keep
talking about the things we're going to
do we leave I feel like that would just
be so great yes and I don't think
there's anything wrong with it people
like to talk about you know his dreamers
and they don't accomplish anything it's
like I'm accomplishing a lot right now
I'm enjoying this is fun again that you
mind that you're sitting in the terrible
chair and I'm sitting in the good chair
didn't even notice that I see ya sorry I
didn't know not I don't have a I don't
it's like it's like first class and
coach it does not make that much
difference to me no you know there was a
moment where I was flying first class a
lot and then I started to fly coach
again you know and I was like I think at
first I was like oh man this is like a
comment on where my career is going but
then I was like no I I like this
actually I don't mind it back here at
all then those tickets are the
difference is so great between the
tickets but not the actual event unless
you're flying to overseas what I do go
first class or business but other than
that I you keep that economy see is just
fine I was at economy flying home from
Chicago one time and Henry Winkler was
in the row behind me with his wife yeah
that is a guy who could fly I mean it
probably was a situation where he wanted
to go when he wanted to go and they
didn't have first class is my guess but
but he he was you know I felt good about
myself and I was in coach right in front
of Henry Winkler
and I got upgraded the way where they go
hey we didn't think it was gonna happen
when you got on but now get up and come
to the front oh man yeah that's amazing
i wish i had known Henry Winkler cuz i
would have said see you later oh man i
would have said it anyway yeah I said or
I'll see you on TV I'm gonna I'm gonna
go up here and still be the same ever
happens that I get something better than
Henry Winkler but Henry Winkler may have
just chosen it I feel like if you you
know I he might be a guy that's like
kept the first dollar he ever earned
what's in saving up for at this point
he's just practicing his you know his
thrift or putting that money into
something better equanimity yeah he's
back there going like I don't like this
that much but I'm dealing with it I
don't know I see you I think there's
something I think there's something to
be to be said for just like it isn't
really that great of a use of your money
no that's absolutely true it really is I
only I only know there's TVs in the back
and now I mean it's just this it's just
the seat space and that doesn't bother
bothered me and our the overhead and I
don't use an overhead I stick my
backpack under the bag can you travel
with Justin over i mean just adjust it
can you do a trip and not take a
suitcase what do you mean not take a
suitcase like just like just my pants
not check can you not check I used to do
that all the time but then I got then I
then we all got CDs and DVDs and
t-shirts and that stuff and so once it
was like okay well now you're oh now
you're running it's a junior achievement
project after the show you know I have
my own little small business right I
have to check a bag for that and so once
i'm checking that bag yeah it's like i'm
gonna bring an extra pair of shorts and
some flip-flops and a pair of tennis
shoes and all that other mine yeah I
could I could easily go without chennai
after show business went to immediately
to a going-out-of-business business you
had like a thriving after after show
business i had one more like
everything's on say everything must go
yeah it's got to go because i wasn't
getting rid of him anyway and i didn't
like seeing the audience again so I I
licensee I like to people who come to
the show that's how you like them too
that's why I give them the very
best show that I possibly can but I
don't I can't I can't go out anymore
this may be trouble for our show that
weird because that's a weird no that's
this is I'm trying to rent that's a
different thing and I'll explain to you
why okay so here's let's talk about to
show about let's reset it cuz this is
people kind of merged into the middle of
the this conversations what we were
talking about and I said let's go start
the podcast we were actually talking
about this plan that you and the point
of the the point of view even coming
over was that we were going to talk
about this yeah and she tell him what
what you yeah started choking so i got i
have purchased some sound equipment cuz
i had thought what i was going to do was
i mean when i started doing this podcast
which has now been going on for a
long time no probably longer than walk
in the room and i still have the you
know that have you have you heard of the
thousand true fans thing you read that
yes yeah yeah so you know made that lets
Lenny Bruce yeah well the guy from what
this guy who started Wired magazine
wrote a little essay about it but did
Lenny Bruce say you needed a thousand
trillions yeah well I also think him
yeah thousand yeah Lenny Bruce mm-hmm
apparently i don't know i read that i
don't feel like he was a decisive
hands-down winner of the game of life
you know look Mussolini said uh what
they say I'd rather he did that Trump
the thing that Trump wreaked quoted it's
a great quote you know what
either have a what is that I'd rather
spend a month as a lion than a lifetime
is a lamb or whatever it is something
like that or better you know I mean and
I was like that's not a bad quote you
know it's a horrible you know you don't
know where any most year quotes came
from you have no idea the guy
said yeah yeah but that's a bad messy
bed could have been a racist it may be
bad messy head maybe he yeah let's not
throw out the baby with the bathwater
that miss Mussolini think me just
because the guy was a fascist dictator
that they strung up and flayed alive in
the street that doesn't mean he didn't
have one or two good idea well right oh
you can't you can't here's here this is
a great debate and not one that we're
gonna have today because we can get back
to our story you can't be Hitler
Mussolini
nexon ah I feel like I want to defend
Nixon a little bit you're he deserves
what's going on Hirohito without having
some just a structural ideas that make
sense in terms of leadership or a policy
I'm just gonna throw you right now
straighten their back into the boat now
I just say Oh basil if you strip them of
their of their ultimate use as as as
mechanics does that make sense Jim see
what I'm saying kind of kind of yeah
let's let's good luck with your book of
you know little pro tips based on Hitler
Nixon and Mussolini and Emperor Hirohito
okay so this is that I didn't we didn't
get everything wrong hoppe's at Urban
Outfitters yeah I hope tips from the
foam I God pro tips from hateful people
yeah yeah good idea good good ideas your
ideas from bed I wish to retail
uncomfortable you are just having this
conversation well I'm just worried you
know nowadays you say one wrong thing I
should but that's but this goes back to
what I was trying the point I was going
to make was like we would be lucky if
there were enough people listening to
this that I could get in some kind of
trouble but because right now it is the
just the true fans Dave and I always
felt about walking only the believers
are listening right now yeah because it
if enough people listen to walk in the
room Dave for sure and I probably should
have been punched one or two times will
with people like I mean I ran into dave
down in Auburn it the comedy festival
and he was down there doing his other
his new thing like Johnny connects to
people who like him and then the people
who don't like him there he's there not
a problem for him which is great well no
that's you know the thing that you know
being middle of the road does not do
much it makes it people comfortable
around you but it doesn't make
for much much sport and watching you
know people love the agenda road like
the edge of the road or the ditch or
they just like in if they like an
opinion like anything that anything has
two sides is interesting you know
because people have taken sides if they
haven't taken sides it doesn't it's not
if there's no impact right you know I
mean if you play it down the middle
people are like well that's nice you
know what I mean but if you're like I'm
gonna do some Hitler protips Hitler's
protest probably going he's not racist
he's saying a funny thing inside of a
joke because you can't mention
that guy and not be a racist I don't
think it's a whole book though I think
that's why you gotta bring Moses led in
there never hero and tell them they said
about he's just not that into you so
that's now I know it is a book oh they
said it wasn't that this is not a whole
book that's what they said every other
publisher except the one that published
us they somebody wrote back this is
barely a magazine article hmm the world
doesn't know trust me if you think if
somebody don't let other people tell you
whether your ideas are good or not no I
that's true that's true but I tell them
our idea I got us right back I got ya
this is might be one of my god one of
the best ones we've done yeah this could
be one of this is these episodes of my
podcasts on ya know I'd stand by it I
mean so far so far so good you can go
back let's not to get it yeah somebody
gets lucky they throw a ball it hits the
big circle and we both go in the dunk
tank that could happen yeah but yeah but
we're not taking calls so the idea is
you and I do a show well I so my dream
was that the podcast will get popular i
bought the sound equipment because i
thought i want to be able to do the live
podcast and and i and maybe I'd do it in
a comedy club while i'm doing a gig as
one of the other nights or later night
or maybe i'll find some other place so i
got i bought this speaker it's not a
expect it's reasonable so i have the
sound system and so now my thing is like
I could do a show anywhere and we were
talking about new ways to do shows for
people who actually want to see us
because sometimes comedy clubs they're
giving away so many tickets to people
who don't know what they're going to
and those are those can be fun to do
shows for those people but I want to do
shows for people who want to come and
see what I want to do and not that I
want to do any kind of know it's not
gonna be middle of the road but it's not
i'm not into any kind of hitler stuff no
no I would do that I would cover that
stuff I or not cover it yeah I mean it
so we can I get it you can custom order
year we do a show we come out we're
funny we talk we have some topics with
it's like a it's like I feel like this
is the show that I that I would like to
do okay where we go on tour well first
of all we could do a little bit of our
stand up if we're touring if it's not
going to be in the same place every week
or around town here where people are
coming again and again yeah before we
can write new material but we could go
in a little tour of california where
where we've got our own sound system i
even rudimentary but not have to seattle
because i know we could do very well in
that from you bottom of from Medford all
the way up to Vancouver it's okay gettin
we're looking to do from crowds from
ideally a hundred people minimum but we
do a show for less if that's how many
people showed up but I think to make it
work there's got to be a hundred to a
hundred to two hundred people more if
they obviously if there's more interest
but we don't think we can make it work
for a hundred two hundred people yeah
and and we come out we've got some
things that we're talking about
currently and and so it's it's not
improvised but we're having a
conversation about stuff that's going on
and then we're taking volunteers having
them come up and we cut their hair I've
been cutting my own hair for years now
and I have just started and I and if you
know me were a fan of mine you know for
a long time it's been my dream to live
had a few of them but I want to have a
barber shop at least run one but i would
love to cut there and everywhere if I
got him had a barber shop but then
wouldn't hire myself and I had to cut in
a different place that's a good story I
think it that would be kind of funny
right yes except I don't think that it's
the case that you wouldn't hire yourself
I think it's a case that you would fire
yourself because you don't even want to
stand out there and sell them a CD of
your comedy show yeah so when you're
cutting their hair
they're going to want to talk to you
about whatever they want to talk to you
about no but it will well that's what
I'm there no no no I get you onto Hitler
that's they're gonna want to talk there
when I go Greg I got a relationship
problems oh my you're like hey Craig
needs to talk to you about relationship
problems like Hitler and it to invade
Poland let me tell you something the
reason now my my agita about after-show
stuff is all about the comedy club I
would happily do it here at a place
where I felt like these are just our
fans mm-hmm these are just people that
you know these are not random folks that
I'm these people have invited us almost
this hunter this group of 100 people
have practically invited us yeah this is
the comedy club is just a different
world I don't and then mine and also
there's so there's a lot of sometimes
there's a lot of tickets that have been
given away a lot of times there's
aggressive people like times there's
negative people you know I know you had
that after your show I've had a little
negative and I'm had a little aggressive
but I'm hadal definitely i also have had
just spacing batery things and I've had
like maybe I hate to watch you a little
closer because I feel like there's
something that you're doing that you you
I maybe you're doing something different
that you shouldn't be no I think that
people are not to blame the victim no
but what I'm saying is I never have that
I when i'm at the-- I can take it I get
a drunk or crowd than you do maybe so
I'm at the gift shop but I mean there's
drunk people at the show often but
people come up and it's it's mostly
pleasant people telling me a big fan of
yours yeah you're a born this and I
haven't brought that a panic attack in
portland and i really get nervous
stomach about selling I don't know what
it is you'll you'll maybe you'll be okay
if we're doing it together yes yeah of
course and when I and when I play with
the band and we're all selling t-shirts
afterwards I have no problem with that
but there's something about the comedy
club thing that I just and also I just
like that time you know if I'm going to
a place in doing one show and then we
got the rest of the night and we can
talk and all that kind of stuff but I
get nervous when people ask me to go
have a drink with them or want to do
more I have a hard time cutting the
relation
chip off I don't know how to make my own
boundaries never follow a hippie to a
second location I mean that's yeah right
I never 30 rock right yeah you'd never
want to go you don't want to leave the
club with no yeah but I'll sit down when
I sometimes and talk to him ya know and
I look and I yeah I look I love people I
genuinely it's not as bad as i think but
i have had i used to have it when we had
to go to to the HBO the Emmys like when
I invited the Emmys and I couldn't I was
like I can't go to this I can't
I don't want to see people I don't want
to think about my career I don't want to
you know I just can't do it I there's
certain there are certain crowd
situations that really make me nervous
because I have no control over them yes
I felt would feel like I had a motto
come of control and also because they
sit came to see a very specific thing
that we're doing mmm you know but but uh
yeah I've always had it I've always had
it and just you know that's okay well
we're not gonna worry about that you're
not concerned about it so I'm not gonna
be concerned about and I can get a case
of this so no no no yeah this would be a
different thing can you remember back to
when we were at the kitchen and we were
going to come in here and start talking
about it because I feel like we got
distracted if there was a lot of waffle
talk then we got on to Hitler and next
time you bought you bought a sound
system right and it's really good it's
really good and it's one of those ones
you can just pack up and put them back
to your car and it sounds just like
you're in any any club really and it can
just be in your living room kind of
thing it's yep it's a it's it's an
all-in-one comedy club anywhere you want
it situation so wait talked about
cutting hair and that kind of stuff and
then I had said to you that because of
recent events and because my you know
I'm have to consider where my career is
going my wife had said maybe you should
go to barber college like you want to
which it takes a year and she said my
only worry is that you can't see well
enough to do it because you've got
what's it called the macula jewelry and
I'm like both near and far-sighted it's
just everything's a blur when the
glasses come off but with the glasses
I'm I feel like I'm fine
and then you do you get a headache and
stuff when you take them off or no I
just can't see anything but I don't know
what it is that is that just cuz you're
cool or do you need the tint to know I
tent for two reasons one the most one of
them is vanity because my lenses are so
thick that my eyes look silly they're
massive oh you look like that crazy
cartoon they live or the races yes guy
yeah they just look huge and the other
one is is yes there are times when too
much light just blinds me and I can I
just see spots and that's the macular
degeneration and that doesn't happen
that often but this prevents it if this
feels like having my eyes in cool water
just feels better so I wish it was a
cool thing I wouldn't I don't have the
courage to be that cool it has a side
benefit of being a cool thing and
sometimes I don't like it though I see
pictures and I go you look like a
douchebag but I can see so you know I
mean the ones that like of the blue I
think you're uncomfortable with your own
coolness which is I take some balls to
say that because you're wearing a
friggin giant skull ring this is a guest
your honor that's another big of the
skull ring the skull ring was from my
niece and I loved it we brought in a
gift shop in Hawaii and it's made of
sterling silver and I was at a big event
the other night I went to a wedding and
a very famous jeweler came up to me and
said where did you get that ring is that
silver and I said no it's a man believe
you can just buy that right off the
internet it's stainless steel this is
stainless yeah yeah can it come in yeah
absolutely oh it's pretty awesome yeah
it's a really cool ring oh yeah it's
really nice yeah I like it and I am I
you know cuz the rest of me is I dress
pretty you know just regular but oh yeah
now I just need a couple of key pieces
and then and then you've also got
tattoos and the glasses in your own hair
cut anyway so we're traveling so anyway
so when I was doing the show as I said
we should do the hair I mean you said
let's do the haircut thing and I said
yes because what I think I'll do is
legally we can give haircuts what was it
wait time I understanding is that you
can only get in trouble for cutting
people's hair if you're charging them so
which are
urging people for a ticket to the comedy
show and then we're taking volunteers to
see if anybody would like to have their
hair cut during the comedy show right
and then we need to know what we're
going to be talking about to each other
and to them during the haircuts and look
I mean that is that's the slight Bugaboo
of this whole plan is that we actually
do have to write the show that we're
going to do yeah well I think I think um
some of the things we might say
look out frizzier or what you know stay
yeah there's gonna be there's gonna be
I'm over it I'm over my head yeah
barbering you I'm gonna bring somebody a
thing I'm going to just hold this is for
the blood you just have to lean forward
a little bit the I will probably only
use clippers and in fades and mohawks
this is the problem with my hair cutting
skills is I use the flowbee and so I
never I've never even seen a flowbee in
action it's loud well we can do that
after this we may have to come back out
after you hear me after you see it yeah
I have to see it I cuz I only I've only
ever heard of heard of it but but anyway
what I said was i'll go out and and
we'll do this tour and I'll get some
idea of not whether I can do this what
do I actually have an attitude before I
go running off to barber college I want
to know if I like being in people's
heads and and helping them because I you
know I know I I love the you know I love
talking about you know style and I have
a whole theory about how close and
everything worked but uh yeah so that
would be the idea to do we got to come
up with a snappy title for it we will we
can't call a barber shop because that's
already some successful movies but yeah
we could yeah we need a big hug won't
cut you well I let's not is that my sure
that does that feel like that's a
promise we can't keep I would say I mean
one of us are you gonna this is a good
this is a good title I think and it's
based slightly it also kind of applies
to your fame area with the relationships
I'm trying not to hurt you
that's pretty great I'm trying not to
hurt you I'm trying not to hurt you but
we have to mention the boat I feel like
the barbershop thing needs to be in it
as well I don't know if I guess if we
both stood there in like it would be
good if we have to take a photo for it I
think you know we have to take a photo
cars both see we should both be wearing
the barber smocks and the well yeah yeah
barbarous marks clippers so dude do you
know anybody who has auto shop where we
can go and get them get our picture
taken I'm sure so we don't need that we
could just have the we could just have
the barbarous know we could do it at an
ice cream place because I always feel
like the barbershop quartets but we also
could just do it in we could also
because we're men without a home we
could do it in an empty lot we can do it
in a on a beach we could do it anywhere
because we're not we're not we don't
have a shot we're bringing the shop to
you garage if you oh my god is great and
Raj door up with all your stuff in there
let you do your store in there why not
right now where we are yeah this looks
exactly it is this is I mean this is you
know um this is perfect yeah so that
would be that would be hit the
barbershop you know whatever was
referred to as the barber shop tour
right now yeah but but that would be it
so you'll come out they would hear
comedy we would do some of our sets we
would then someone to come up from the
audience and we would cut hair and and
see how it goes and then Jake and maybe
even me we'll have a few items for sale
afterwards in your for a you'll be
hanging out and we hanging out I think
there's got to be a little bit of our
act or material kind of stuff for sure
to but not a lot you know so we'll think
of it this way one of us goes out and
does 20 the other person goes out and
goes 20 and then we do 20 minutes of a
haircut as an hour yeah well I was even
thinking yeah I was thinking that oil
and then we've got I feel like maybe a
little bit less even and and then we've
got
topical items from the news and then
when we were cutting the person's hair
we're getting a little biography of them
yeah we're like who are you where you
from how's everything going are you you
know little relates people what do
people talk about when they're getting
their hair cut we talk about their
relationships you know which not to put
you right into your strong so that would
be fine but yes so it appears and let me
get three microphones the person cutting
can only just talk off mic it'll be a
small enough theater but then you would
have the mic if I was cutting and then
the person who was being interviewed
they'd have yeah I think well the person
who's cutting has got a lavalier mic on
and then the then the other person has
got a handheld and they're doing the
interview back I'm talking you're
talking about I'm talking you're talking
where that person is getting their hair
k-member bind at some point that we can
just I think by the end of this if we if
we get good enough it we should just
throw people up there in the chair and
be able to just do the whole thing
talking while we're cutting hair Barbara
well let's face it also I feel like at
least with the flowbee haircuts the
amount of time that it takes to do it is
pretty like I can knock out one of those
in pretty short order 10 minutes 10
minutes yeah so so you're talking a lot
and then you're doing a little and then
you're talking some more and then you're
doing a little right because also you
got to agree like if there's a good
night oh can I that's my own hair I'm
cutting my own hair so I don't have to
have a conversation with myself about
what it's one of your goals like what do
you want how do you want this to look
when we're done I know that already well
I think what we do is we'll probably
Sketchup a couple of the haircuts and
we'll give you an option and because
we're not neither of us are you use
scissors with yours mmm know a little
bit of trimming the year the side ear
area right but you could do that with
clippers and we could say that we're not
bringing any scissors I don't know what
we get out of saying we're not bringing
any scissors because I want to bring it
going to bring scissors well because the
scissors and I think without with with
no scissors it means people won't
there's a pretty good chance they won't
get cut when I say
I'm trying not to hurt you i feel like
that means more if there's a possibility
that i might hurt you so I feel like at
one point we want to just get a straight
razor out just to show people like look
I have this but I'm just keeping it in
the bag that's not a bad idea alright
here's some other dangerous barbering
tools that are not even going to get
into play today yeah yeah maybe yeah I
feel like there's a lot of people
listening to this right now going no way
am I ever going to go to that you know
operation forget there's an all I can
say to them is like it I think it's good
for you to stay away and i would say i
would disagree because i think that
still despite its popularity the pie
that podcast community is still a
pioneering community they're there
they're people that want they want to
have an adventure like that they whoa we
want to say greg behrendt gave me the
same hair he had when he this podcast
dog pills I am pioneering yeah I'm out I
found I found two backwater Eddie a
podcast yeah and I mean who are
listening to this these are people we're
gonna go hand fishing ya know I'm gonna
do Barbara minute I still feel I'm still
feel like it has to have I feel like
that I like the title I think it's smart
oh we haven't agreed on the time yeah
that's not that's think I'm gonna bring
some chow you know there is chalk that
you can use to color people's hair now
stay colored for like two days yeah yeah
yeah yeah well bring the colored rocks
so okay well and if you're a real barber
and you're not going to turn us in we'd
love it if you came to the show we'd
love to hear what you have to say mmm
maybe we bring a real barber so that he
can charge for haircuts and we just take
a cut because we're renting him a chair
in our shop and what got that bale area
so he we just want to have haircuts look
Jake and I just need to have haircuts
happening while we're doing while we're
talking it makes me it's how I relax but
that's what's great about the movie
barbershop if you if you watch the bar
there's a new one that you can watch in
the movies in the seat on your airplane
and that's how I just watched barber
shop the next cut yeah it's really funny
the barbershop movies are funny well you
could do a thing where you were saying
like we pay the barber out of our feet
let's say we just give him a flat you
know 50 bucks and then you can pick you
get a flowbee you can get a faux hawk a
mohawk a buzz cut or you just get a
haircut just a regular old haircut that
he will not talk the barber he will not
get to talk he doesn't get to talk now
yeah and he can be local we gotta draw
the line somewhere oh yeah he's not
gonna do he's not gonna talk well we're
prepped well i got i think the odds are
good that we're gonna get a barber who
is a good talker and so maybe he'll talk
so okay so we've got I feel like we've
got a good concept for this show and
then we gotta we don't want to talk
about the specific writing of the what's
going to happen during the show now
because that then we're giving them were
we don't want to show too much of our
hand but we're laying the groundwork the
people are listening here they're saying
man I want to come to that barber show
our next step is where are we going to
do the first Barbara show now we could
do it with my sound system in the
driveway of your new place that you're
moving to we could do it I can't I can't
do it here and obviously you can't do it
at your house either so we got to decide
to we want to try and do this at a place
where there's already a place like would
we would we say to someone who had a
venue that we know we want to try this
or do you think we'd be better off doing
it at it I had a locker start in any
place that's conventional I think we
should if someone had a gallery space a
loft space a ok we're going to take a
walk we're going to eat lunch this I
feel like we're at a good stopping place
now yep and we can talk more later on
this if we want or this can be the end
after we have to say some funny things
at the end to make it good yeah but
we'll take a walk I've also got the
Moose Lodge which I don't think we have
time to go I don't think it's open right
now but the Moose Lodge is a place that
I haven't been in for a while but I'm a
member right um that sounds like the
right place already I want to just go
there I want to be a member yeah it's a
weird I haven't been there for years so
I don't know what it's like right now
but it's been weird sounds good well
start maybe this will start our own
Lodge
I think the time is right for I can't so
I joined the Moose Lodge when John Ross
who I'm who I've done his life story and
I've just got to listen to it and edit
it for the podcast because he's had a
great career but he was he's he is my
best friend was my best friend now he's
moved away but he joined the Moose Lodge
when he was having his 40th birthday
party and that would that was where you
could rent a place and have guests
cheaper than hiring another Hall you
know you become a member of the Moose
Lodge and you're allowed to use the
facility and so he joined then and so I
joined because we were friends and it
was like we're going to join this funny
club for that older men it's a thing
that older but their thing is we need
young guys like you we were young guy
you're a young guy at 40 at the moose
lodge and we need young guys and I can't
you and then John got involved and there
were all these economic issues you know
because they wanted everything to be
cheap and they didn't want to pay more
money they had a steak dinner that
included the steak potato a vegetable
and then coffee and it was like seven
dollars that's what they were charging
people so they were losing money because
the cheapest steaks they could get it
was costing him but they wouldn't raise
the price because the members were
revolting so that so they're funding it
out of the dues that people are paying
who aren't people who even show up that
then they would do this thing so it was
really hard to get them to do things out
of their comfort zone right at the moose
lodge well the thing is I you're about
to say I think the time is right about
this and I have had many conversations
with you know am I you know when I first
started thinking that I wanted to have a
barbershop a while ago you know the
whole idea was to have a place that was
really sort of a gathering spot for you
know for dudes really and for in a place
where I you know in my version of it you
know there's a there's it's a no
internet space for a while you know and
you come in and you know there's
everyone everyone employed there's over
40 uh-huh over 40 so that you have a
place to get wisdom from people who are
a little bit older than you you wouldn't
hire young people because the tournament
rich you with young people can go
but they show they should want to go
young men should want to go and go
should want to help me with my marriage
you can talk to me about my my
mortgage my marriage my you know what
will my career direction like that kind
of thing where you get a bunch of guys
oh you know very similar to what you're
talking about that's what those lodges
were for they you know that somehow they
do good in the community but you have a
gathering space because I think men more
than ever need a place to go talk and
they're not gonna go do it at a bar you
know well my problem as a man of a
certain age who feels like he's figured
some I mean the joke that I did in my
act was I feel like finally now I know I
know some and no one gives a
right the problem isn't me having things
to say the problem is getting finding
people who want to listen to them thank
you this is good time to say thank you
to the listeners we're listening yeah no
no thank you no I'll tell you but I'm
gonna tell you this it has changed it
used to be women asking me for advice
and stuff after shows i get its men and
a lot of times it's just a comic on the
road men come to me all the time with
their relationship problems with you
know just to talk about career stuff you
know just to talk just to talk and
marriage is a big one and kids is
another one okay so let's stir this out
right now because there are people
listening to this if you have questions
that you would like us to address at our
barbering show whether you can come or
not that's another question because we
may be cost prohibitive for you to fly
to wherever we are right but if you have
some ideas of things that we could talk
about in the barber and show please 10
send me an email jake a jake this calm
or you can at tweet me if you want but
then that's a short question it's easier
if you email me and thanks to the people
who've email me questions about other
things that I asked I'm getting around
to that and I will have a space so I am
abstention so Greg Gregory berent calm
that is going to be the home of
everything that I do is just Gregory
berent com it's just it's just a bit
it's just a very very very basic there's
news and my tour dates that's it and
again on the mailing list thing and I
will have an email address for you and
that's it I'm so I don't think I need to
spell Jake this calm but I think you
need to spell Gregory baron yeah
yeah GRE g 0 ry beh r en dt mhm and that
d are just just just too many consonants
and isn't it do you feel like do you
feel like it's trouble oh it's been has
it been a problem in your life always it
was a big mistake I just could not
arrive at something I could live with
that wasn't my last name I mean you know
I guess out changing both names and you
went Gregory though now you don't go by
Gregory do you um sometimes when people
say it but not know only only family
members but I lost greg behrendt calm
and then you had it and then you lost us
yeah I had it and then I lost it so
because there are now quite a few Greg
parents in the world so I like Gregory
behrendt com it's still the one that
comes up if you put in greg behrendt and
yeah so it's that's my place on the
internet Gregory Behrendt calm for now
for now oh yeah no we're good no I'm I
haven't got to go away I have a very big
theory about all that stuff I i am going
to try to I really because I have seen
zero upside the only thing I've ever
done that's had an upside was the
podcast oh and I but even tweeting about
the podcast didn't do anything it's
tweeting its food I find please waiting
is for tweeters and my and I don't like
my Facebook page and I don't I don't I
like my Facebook page yeah I don't have
any activity on there and then I don't
like having facebook either so any best
I am G best dot com what is that that's
my that's that's the website that I'm
buying two for you G best because it's
gb yes I gb EST I like that I was I am I
just wanted to have them yeah I just
want to find the one place and don't
look I'll yeah no I get it here and
that's why that's my websites check this
calm and then I'm at take this on
Twitter and Jake this podcast because
it's I decided yeah that's good I
thought I picked a good one but I don't
know who knows anyway so are we going
for to eat lunch now yeah what kind of
food do you want ah I don't know maybe
like a sandwich okay i will figure it
out yeah figured I I feel like this was
good i think i was really good solid
work solid work i started i'm not i'm
not positive about the ending Oh thought
that he was good would it do you okay
say something every time when I when I
did the other podcast there were just
days rose like that was the worst thing
we've ever done and people writing they
go probably my favorite podcast you ever
people get tired people get hired two
people get tired yeah and they don't
they don't care how it ends yeah i'm
looking for a this is not a comedy set
they're not looking for a closer
this is the other thing they thought it
ended and it's not over right well they
were said about happy yeah we're still
talking what's that is that a fish hook
no that's like one of those pacific
island too that's right i got this from
my aunt lives in in hawaii I don't
really nice okay I wanted all right
Hawaii that was the other thing about
you moving to why ok it would that's
gonna make noise where you're doing I'm
gonna turn it off all right okay then
does the end you have any final words
lie okay I can't
you know when dr. Jim rain screams like
that it just makes me happy it just
makes me happy uh I hope you're happy
Hey so while this was playing you know
this was me I had to play it again in
real time the way the technology of this
works is I just had to play this again
and while that was happening I went to
the i went to the textile recycling
center at the City Hall of Santa Monica
which is where I live please don't stalk
me but if you want to it's going to be a
while before I get to the textile
recycling center again so i took some
textiles there to be recycled and came
back and one of the things that happened
on the roads we're all in this together
but please oh my god so i'm driving in
my car of the car today because I'm
picking my mother up at the airport in a
minute which is why I can't talk too
long right now so I have the car today
and I'm driving I'm going straight and
coming towards me is a woman on a
bicycle and she's in the left hand lane
getting ready to turn left but when
you're on a bicycle you in the work
you're in the world of cars and traffic
you have to obey those rules so she's on
the other side of this the intersection
waiting to turn left and i'm in the car
going straight towards her and she
decides I don't want to be at a bicycle
and have to obey the world of bicycles
and vehicles I don't want to be a
pedestrian do what I want she gets off
the bike and just steps into the
crosswalk and walks right in front of me
to make her left turn to get to the
corner and I'm like what the hell I get
you know it's it was the weirdest thing
like she turned from a bicycle vehicle
into a pedestrian in a second and just
assumed that I was not going to kill her
and it turned out to be a safe
assumption but if she didn't he's
luckily she gave me barely enough time
to realize oh that person is not doing
what anyone thought they would do and
she in her mind didn't question that
what she was doing was dangerous at all
and this was a grown-up lady I should
point out you know there's plenty of
young people doing ridiculous things
with this woman
could have been 35 40 years olds and she
was doing it very dangerous thing so be
careful out there ladies and gentlemen
take care of yourselves don't give up
there'll be plenty of time to give up
later and don't do some dumb thing that
gets you killed that can happen ladies
and gentlemen accidents happen every day
do not cause one if you can all help it
but if you're on the other end you see
someone doing something stupid please
don't kill them please don't kill them
let them go let someone else teach them
the hard lesson you don't want to be a
murderer you don't want to carry around
that for the rest of your life and let's
all we're all in this together be nice
to each other I will talk to you next
week uh I hope I hope that's what's
gonna happen I feel like I feel like I
got my groove back I hope you get your
group I hope you've got your group I
hope you never lose your groove I hope
you perpetually maintain your groove for
as long as you both shall live thank you
listeners see you next time
never
you heard that I heard it hurt it hurt
it hurt it hurt it hurt it hurt it hurt
it